كشف المبعوث الامريكي الخاص بايران روبرت
مالي ان رئيس جو بايدن مستعد لاستخدام
الخيار العسكري بهدف منع ايران من حيازه
سلاح النووي في حال فشلت العقوبات
والديبلوماسيه مضيفا انه اذا لم تنجح
العقوبات والضغط والديبلوماسيه ستلجا
اداره الرئيس الامريكي الى استخدام القوه
العسكريه ضد طهران كملاذ اخير لمنع
امتلاكها السلاح النووي واكد مالي ان رئيس
بيدن مازال يعمل في ان تغير ايران مسارها
الحالي مشيرا الى ان المفاوضات غير
المباشره بين واشنطن وطهران توقفت بعد ما
قدمت ايران مطالب اضافيه لا علاقه لها
لصلب الاتفاق النووي وكرر مالي في الاول
الاخيره ان واشنطن لم تعد ترى البرنامج
النووي لايران منفصلا عن القضايا الاخرى
[موسيقى]